what I was surprised to see is how
almost every cell in the body changes
its own metabolism inside the cell when
we change the diet what we eat ends up
in our immune cells we're not just
feeding ourselves our body we are
feeding our immune cells
[Music]
will these fuels that they're using help
us fight cancer and fight infection or
will it hinder us
[Music]
Lydia Lynch is an immunologist and her
lab is studying the effects of
metabolism on immune cells like T cells
if we were going to run a marathon in a
few minutes we wouldn't have you know a
steak and a hot chocolate or something
because that would leave us tired that
would be a lot of process and there will
be a lot of fat and we wouldn't be able
to run the marathon as well that is the
same as the immune system if we have an
infection a pathogen in us and we get a
fever the amount of energy that that
takes for the immune system to respond
is actually the same as running the
marathon it's the same amount of energy
the immune system is always active with
B cells producing antibodies and T cells
speeding around looking for infections
and illnesses like cancer
energy but when a pathogen enters or
when a tumor forms that's when it needs
a lot of energy they're crazy like each
cell really ramps up its use of energy
if we're going to feed it the equivalent
of a steak and a hot chocolate before it
has to you know whiz around it's not
going to do a good job and we're going
to become susceptible to infection and
cancer more and so we have to feed our
body well in order for it to be able to
do the job that we wanted to do
could take your T cells out of the blood
and we can put them in a dish and feed
them mediates like food for cells if I
put in more fat into that media and then
look at the cells I'll see now that your
cells have taken up the lipids and now
they've got fat inside of them
because fat can be toxic to the cell it
turns on protective mechanism to protect
it from the lipotoxicity from the fat
itself killing it but that's all it's
doing really it's not doing any of its
original job
if we look at what white cells we have
about 10 percent of them are natural
killer cells and it's a cool name
because they're Natural Born Killers
they're ready to kill that's their main
job and if we take them from someone's
blood and we put them in a dish with a
tumor cell they go towards it they're
attracted to it they recognize it as a
tumor and they go over to it and they
stick onto it and they have these two
killing machineries like a gun perforin
that shoots the holes in the tumor cell
and then they have granzymes granzymes
are the bullets they go into the hulls
and they kill they blow up the tumor
cell if you take these NK cells from a
person living with obesity or if you've
had a very fatty meal for a few months
and and put them with a tumor cell we
were surprised they still go over it's a
little bit slower they still recognize
the tumor cell and they still attach
onto it but now they can't fire the gun
they don't have as much bullets they
don't make the grand slams and so now
you have an NK cell that can see the
tumor but it can't do that much about it
and we have billions of these cells so
you know if everything is working slower
or not working at all then the tumor
wins the bowel
it's not the case of you know this is
the only reason you get enhancer you
could be genetically predisposed and no
matter watching how healthy are you'll
still get cancer and but by choosing
diet you are stacking the odds in your
favor diet might not be the answer to
avoiding cancer entirely but
understanding how these lifestyle
variables impact us at the immune cell
level helps us get towards more targeted
interventions and improve treatments
be to become practical about it I think
we fed mice a high fat diet you know an
obesogenic diet but the source of fat
was changed far from notes far from
Plants far from animals and then we've
seen that over time cancer was growing
more in the maisteka fat from animals
and I was super surprised at that
because we didn't design it that way oh
my God it really it's not the Obesity
level it's something happening in all
the cells in response to where the fat
is coming from what we put in is more
important than just the number on the
weighing scales the next day I was at a
conference in California queuing up for
the dinner and I said do you have a
vegetarian option which I've never done
my whole life
I'm not a vegetarian but it actually
really did finally hit home that you
know I'm feeding my immune system here I
should feed it well it's what the doctor
has said for many years right eat well
and exercise I didn't really listen to
it for most of my life because I just
thought it was just generic advice but
now we're actually seeing if we eat well
the body shifts what it spends its
energy on what we eat goes into the cell
what the cell eats changes what it makes
and but I didn't like liked that advice
before now I do because I understand how
it actually works
we need collaboration between different
scientists immunologists don't have all
the information on nutrition
nutritionists don't have all the
information on the immune system
oncologists who understand cancer better
than anyone don't have the information
on nutrition and Immunology
it's only when we share all of these
ideas and data together and be open you
know that's the whole point of of being
a scientists is to serve the the
community and to you know serve Humanity
by sharing the information to hopefully
get to a result that will help Humanity
that only happens by collaboration
Lydia's work shows that our immune cells
need to be given the right ingredients
to work together successfully
and a diverse Melting Pot of research
groups is a great way to advance our
understanding of human health in the
21st century
just make sure you give the scientists a
decent lunch at the conference